i've seen the finale now
a couple of times uh it remains really
exciting each time
and i wanted to get your you get get
like your initial reaction to
reading that script and seeing all the
different things that were going to
happen into it in it
yeah it's uh it's always fun to to read
the
the it's all it's been it's always a
trip really reading the finales on these
shows because they
uh they always deliver um
the first i mean both the first season
finale
and this one um had me crying
when uh when i read the script um and uh
literally like tears were like dripping
down
on my ipad um and uh
yeah and and this one didn't fail doing
that uh as well
um and of course it was more emotional
because it was also um you know knowing
that
a couple of dear friends will not be
part of the
the continuation and and you know
michael in particular
uh it was one of the great gifts of this
show for me was the the friendship that
that i
built with mike and um and it was
something
you know the friendship between
ed and gordo was so beautifully written
in the show and um and it's
it just kind of rubbed off
rubbed off on me and michael
we were both going through some
difficult stuff in different phases of
these shootings
uh you know of this the recording of
this series so it
um when we were there for each other and
and also you know he had quite a journey
over the course of the second season
uh and did this incredible
transformation and
and it put him in pretty dark places and
he was also going through a lot of [ __ ]
uh during this um
so it was it was a
i don't know i got really moved by it uh
but by that
and uh and when we shot the the funeral
scenes
uh it was uh
it was like you know it was it wasn't
i was sort of burying a a two-year era
of my life you know that it was you know
me and him like playing cards and you
know it
we got to know each other doing these
first scenes uh
in the show and then you know building
this friendship more and of course we're
still going to be friends
and and you know that's a that's a gift
that this show gave us but
you know it just it got i got really
emotional about it um
and um yeah so so that that was that was
definitely a part of the experience
uh when reading it it was like [ __ ]
um i'm not gonna play around with my guy
anymore
on the show anyway yeah i i just
realized
i never thought i never i never realized
this would be a possibility did he show
up to watch the funeral scenes being
shot
no no okay and uh i wouldn't have wanted
that
really yeah no it
you know we're we're always sort of
playing games in our minds right and
uh we take the emotions that come
naturally and use
them and if there are no real emotions
coming then
we have to create something in our
imaginations or in our memories and
that's sort of part of the profession
and um
and here there was just so much real
emotion available so
you don't want anything to um to
interfere with that of course
uh yeah he he i believe i heard that you
you and he were flying buddies or you
were both interested in learning how to
fly
together yeah after the first season we
we said that you know let's get a
pilot's license together
um and then we never we never got
cracking with that
so uh but now i'm flying i'm i'm about
10 hours in so
i'm gonna get my pilot's license before
the end of the year
that's wonderful congrats yeah it's so
fun
i feel like you know i don't want to
make you you're not going to tell me too
much i imagine about where season three
might go
but oh i'll spoil it too i'll tell you
everything okay go for it that's what i
do but you gotta
first take down my bank account number
okay it's
city national yeah well i mean i think
the one thing that feels pretty clear is
that if ed comes back it'll be in a very
different capacity just because he'll be
you know over 10 years older um
and you know you know for you though i
know that
you know you have a you have a you have
a track record of like
liking to do a show for maybe a season
uh
you know it was what it wasn't like
doing the two seasons of the show
yeah uh so this was the first the
time that i signed on for you know more
years you know so i signed on for three
years for this
um but you know who knows
who knows
the the older you get the the more of
a of an actor challenge the the playing
the age becomes
and uh and it's that's pretty fun it's
it's a pretty fun thing to play
with so uh
i am i'm not i'm not hating it
while we're shooting season three not at
all it's uh
it's actually getting more interesting
it's interesting so how deep in the
season three are you right now
we're still shooting the first and
second episode
so we're pretty early but you know uh uh
i'm i'm
i've finished my work on the first
episode i'm now working on the second
so yeah we're we're into it we're
definitely in the in the thick of it
well that's my time with you thank you
so much for doing this today
and it's always a pleasure talking to
you liz well thank you i appreciate that
and i can't wait to see what happens
with season three
i know can't wait to show you